the other hand the women were training
Youth and Purity so like every time we
date a guy we run the risk of you know
it's an extra person that you slept with
it's an extra like I'll give you an
example I've never lived with a guy if I
were to live with a guy now that's
something and it didn't work out that's
something I did with him that I would
also do with hypothetically my husband
right so it's like we're running the
risk of doing things with you that we
can't give to our husband we're running
the risk which I know each girl is
different but what percent of girls are
waiting till they're married not many so
I'm talking in modern times okay and
then we have right so it's like okay you
got two years of my youth or three years
of my youth and the women get
increasingly anxious each year that we
put gave you our youth we gave you our
Purity and it's not gonna work out and
we're not gonna get what we want which
is long-term commitment